there was a different world I'm gonna
make a statement that I believe in more
than anything more than I believe that
the Sun will actually come up tomorrow I
know that marketers ruin everything
and I'm a proud marketer I am that I
can't wait to ruin snapshot do you know
why I do you know what yeah I'm serious
you know why I stayed up for three days
three weeks excuse me on vine to figure
out how to ruin it that's the truth now
the nice thing is ruining it these days
is making native ads and it's getting a
little bit better as we continue to hack
of this culture but that's what it is
marketers haven't ruined it yet Groupon
and LivingSocial hadn't come along yet
and emailed you [ __ ] you didn't want
every day 16 times a day marketers
ruined email marketers by that purpose
are ruining social media social media
looked a lot different in 2006 and 7
than it does right now it's what we do
it's how it rolls so when I had a
hundred thousand followers on Twitter
compared to the million that I have now
I got dramatically higher click throughs
and engagement on the stuff that I
tweeted out because the supply and
demand curve was in a good place
we just ruin things it's what we do
banner ads I'll talk about banner ads in
1996 when I ran my first banner ads with
twenty four percent click-through 2.4
out of every 10 people that went to a
website click the banner ad cuz like who
what's this [ __ ] thing right like
that's what it was and when I and when
Google AdWords came along I bought the
word wine for 10 cents and known it for
nine and a half months before anybody
bid me up and now it's a 14 dollar word
right and then when banner retargeting
cookie ads came along I cookie the [ __ ]
out of all of you when people thought
you ate that [ __ ] right I knew what it
was I used it and it worked better it
converted more we weren't used to being
followed around people even sent emails
like wow you guys are buying a lot of
ads everywhere because we didn't even
know that was the behavior yet and so
over and over and over it's a very
simple game innovation comes along
there's opportunity first move advantage
there's a value proposition it gets more
expensive Facebook dark posts if you're
an app developer that really understands
what's going on how many people here are
familiar with the term Facebook dark
posts raise your hand all right so let
me really get into
book unpublished posts is the proper
terminology dart poses a slang term
Facebook right this second you have the
ability to target every single person on
Facebook you don't need a single one of
them to be a fan you have the ability to
make a picture a video and infographic
whatever you want and then target the
living [ __ ] out of it to data levels
that we've never seen before downright
to like master card behavior you want to
sell some soap pretty cool to like
target somebody who actually bought soap
in the last 30 days
wanna buy soap that wasn't your brand
soap in the last 30 days you can target
the three hundred thousand people in the
last 30 days that bought a soap that's
not your soap and you get to put
something in front of them targeting at
a level we'd never seen before the
conversion rates that I've seen on
facebook unpublished posts in the last
three months art a single best digital
asset marketing thing I've seen since
Google AdWords in 99 2000 yet the
hyperbole of organic Reach drop going
down has all the marketing rags talk
about why it's bad and why debating
people if they should double down or
triple down or get completely out this
is the common story over and over again